[Musik]
Minuten unverschämt okay nach 30
das neue Jahr beginnt wie das alte
aufgehört hat mit großen Sorgen um die
Ukraine heute reiste Außenministerin
Annalena baerbock überraschend in die
zerstörte Stadt in der Ostukraine und
ihr Kollege Kollege der Bart bei diesem
Besuch erneut um Kampfpanzer und schwere
Waffen nach der Entscheidung des
Bundeskanzlers Schützenpanzer zu liefern
steigt der Druck auf Deutschland weiter
wer Bock betonte aber dass man nur
gemeinsam mit den Verbündeten handeln
will Kampfpanzer nicht ausgeschlossen
was muss der Westen liefern unser Thema
heute in der Phönix Runde
in diesem Krieg hat es immer wieder
Momente gegeben wo wir abwägen mussten
und dann entscheiden mussten in
schwierigen Situationen wie können wir
weitere Menschen leben retten deswegen
haben wir dann zuerst Panzerhaubitzen
geliefert Luftverteidigung geliefert und
sind jetzt in den letzten Tagen einen
großen Schritt gegangen auch Marder
Panzer zu liefern um eben bei der
Befreiung von Städten zu unterstützen
für uns ist wichtig dass wir es
gemeinsam mit unseren Verbündeten tun
weil eben der Frieden in der Ukraine nur
gesichert werden können wenn wir als
internationale Gemeinschaft geschlossen
stehen das war die Außenministerin auf
ihrem Rückweg im Zug aus der Ukraine das
ganze Interview in den tagessthemen
herzlich willkommen zu dieser Phönix
Runde zur ersten Runde in diesem Jahr
für das für uns ja eigentlich alle
wünschen würden endlich über Frieden
oder Verhandlungen berichten zu können
davon sind wir weit entfernt wir
diskutieren über Waffenlieferungen und
zwar mit diesen Gästen Thomas wiegalt
Journalist mit den Schwerpunkten
Verteidigungs und Sicherheitspolitik und
über den Krieg in der Ukraine berichtet
er vor allem auf sein blogaugen gerade
aus ich begrüße Andreas zumach auch
freier Journalist und Publizist der hat
berichtet aus der Schweiz und bei
un-korrespondent für die Tageszeitung
taz und in den 80er Jahren hat er
Friedensdemos organisiert herzlich
willkommen Kerstin Münstermann sie ist
Leiterin des Berliner parlamentsbüros
der Rheinischen Post und zugeschaltet in
levif ist uns sehr geh zum Lenny er ist
Gründer und direkter des European
resiliens Initiative Centers und hat
zuvor das Büro der
Heinrich-Böll-Stiftung in Kiew geleitet
schönen guten Abend nach livife sie
waren vor einigen Tagen auch selbst noch
in rakif wie würden Sie sagen wie ist
die Situation ja im Moment in leviv in
Harke was erleben Sie dort gerade
ja guten Abend und Grüße aus Liebe also
hier im Westen der Ukraine sind alle so
ziemlich sicher aus also soweit es in
einem in einem Land aussehen kann welche
sich mitten im Krieg befindet also Strom
gibt es ab und zu also von lufthanen gab
es in den letzten paar Tagen so keine
keine weiterarbeiten zuvor schlugen auch
die russische Raketen hier in äh lief im
Osten oder tief ist ganz anders ganz
anders also
liegt nur 40 km Luftlinie direkt von der
großen Grenze und wird ständig von der
russischen beschossen und von russischen
Landes Landratten es gibt so die ganzen
Stadthalle in welche von den Osten
gezielt zerstört worden weil wir Russen
kann gibt nicht übernehmen konnten und
offensichtlich auch der Rache wegen
dieses Stadtwerke auch zum Großteil der
russische Sprache ich war und sich
trotzdem benutzen nicht
kapituliert hätte also wollten die
russische Armee die Stadt einfach
zerstören und macht mir soweit dies
konnten weiter war ich in easyum istum
befand sich eine kleine Türkei statt
etwas südlich von karke befand sich
sechs Monate lang in der russischen
Besatzung dann wurde easy knapp drei
Monaten befreit und da ist die Lage ganz
schrecklich also da steht im Zentrum der
Stadt kein Haus ohne Schaden also die
Häuser sind entweder beschädigt stark
beschädigt oder komplett zerstört die
Leute wenige Leute wird wieder geblieben
sind die leben in kleinen privaten
Häusern auch total beschädigt sind man
erzählt die schrecklichen Geschichten
über die grilltaten die russische Armee
dort eingerichtet hat also da
gewaltigungen
Exekutionen und so weiter und so fort
also man wartet auf uns und man fragt
uns ständig wo ist die deutsche Hilfe wo
uns endlich die deutschen Panzer welche
die Ukraine brauchen um ihre Städte zu
befreien vor allem ihre Leute welche
immer noch in der unterrussischen
Besatzung bleiben also das ist eine
klare Forderung die heute auch wieder
natürlich gestellt wurde sprechen wir
gleich natürlich noch mal ausführlich
dazu wird aber gerne noch mal erstmal
hier die Gäste noch in der Runde mit
dazu einbeziehen Herr Wiegold die
Außenministerin fährt dorthin sagt
hört den die Forderung erneut eben auch
schwere Waffen zu liefern Kampfpanzer zu
liefern jetzt hat ja Deutschland
zugesagt im aderpanzer zu liefern
Schützenpanzer was bedeutet das wie viel
was für ein Unterschied kann das schon
machen für den Kriegsverlauf
Schützenpanzer sind nun andere
Waffensystem als Kampfpanzer sie sind
leichter gepanzert weniger stark
bewaffnet sie transportieren Infanterie
und das ist natürlich etwas worum die
Ukraine ja auch gebeten hat eben nicht
nur um Kampfpanzer es geht ja auch darum
bei diesem kämpfen am Boden u rheinische
Soldaten an die Frontlinie in diese
Gebiete zu bringen wo sie agieren sollen
und wir kennen Bilder die sehen wir
immer wieder wo Ukraine auf Pickups also
auf offenen Lkw in diese Kampfgebiete
fahren
die Todeszahlen die wir nicht genau
wissen wie viel gefallen es gibt wie
viel verwundete haben auch mit solchen
Dingen zu tun also zum einen es ist
stärker durchsetzungsfähig wie das
Militär sagt aber es erhöht auch den
Schutz der ukrainischen Soldaten dazu
macht wir haben gehört oder krank
ist befreit worden eben nachdem es von
den Russen besetzt war und zerstört
worden ist unter anderem mit der Hilfe
von deutschen Waffen wie wichtig finden
Sie es dass Panzer in die Ukraine
weitergeliefert werden damit die Ukraine
wehrhafter ist ich finde es deswegen ich
will nicht wichtig weil ich glaube dass
der Westen einer großen Täuschung
unterliegt zu glauben dass auch nur
irgendeines der politischen Ziele die
mit diesen Waffenlieferungen verbunden
werden öffentlich erreichbar ist weder
das Minimalziel eines militärischen
erschöpfungspads noch das weitergehende
Ziel russische Truppen hinter die Linien
vom 24 Februar zurückzudrängen und schon
gar nicht das extrem Ziel den gesamten
dombas und auch die Krim militärisch
zurückzuerobern das sind ja die Politik
erklärten Ziele ich glaube das deswegen
unrealistisch und da braucht man nicht
Pazifist zu sein weil
die russische Überlegenheit trotz aller
bekannten Schwierigkeiten die die haben
nach wie vor sehr groß ist und dazu
kommt dass Putin die eskalationsdominanz
hat das sehen wir in diesen Wochen auf
grausamsterweise mit den Angriffen zur
Zerstörung über lebenswichtige
Infrastruktur und auch die größere
Durchhaltefähigkeit hat im Vergleich zu
ukrainischen Regierung und auch zu dem
Regierung nein das meine ich nicht aber
ich glaube wenn wir so weitermachen und
es gibt ja auch keine rote Linien auch
die feinsinnigen Unterscheidung die
natürlich waffentechnisch alle
nachvollziehbar sind Kollege Gesundheits
eben gemacht aber die Entscheidung was
ist nun schwer was es weich und während
wer nimmt es wie war wann mein Putin wir
seien nun im Krieg das ist seiner Wilke
überlassen da halte ich überhaupt nichts
von nur wir sind auf einem Weg wo dann
ein paar Wochen die Forderung völlig
logisch steht auch Kampfflugzeuge und so
weiter und so weiter und wie gesagt mein
Hauptpunkt ist ich halte das für
unrealistisch die damit verbundenen
Ziele zu erreichen und deswegen muss
jetzt alles getan werden um zumindest
eine Waffen Ruhe hinzubekommen und dann
auch ein Verhandlungsprozess Frau
Münstermann trotzdem gibt es ja in der
gab's in der Bundesregierung eine
Änderung durch diesen durch die
Entscheidung zu sagen wir liefern jetzt
diesen Marder Schützenpanzer das haben
ja einige in der Koalitionen FDP und
Grüne ja schon länger gefordert wodurch
ist es dazu gekommen dass Bundeskanzler
Scholz zugestimmt hat
Olaf Scholz glaube ich hat in dem Punkt
so ein bisschen dieses halbzuges ihn
halb sank dahin also er hat lange
gezögert er hat immer immer wieder das
ist ja das Mantra was er seit einem Jahr
vertritt gesagt nur in Abstimmung mit
Partnern und da gab es schon länger
Gespräche also kommuniziert wurde es
dann an einem Tag am drei König es war
die Sternsinger im Kanzleramt und so
weiter aber Emanuel macron der
französische Präsident war vorgeprescht
in Deutschland musste man auch eine
Abstimmung mit US-Präsident beiden
warten das war nicht so einfach aber
dann hat man es gemeinsam kommuniziert
und den gingen viele Gespräche voraus
und er hat da eine Linie verlassen die
er bisher hatte nämlich immer zu warnen
und zu sagen je mehr sich auch
Deutschland einlässt in der Ukraine
desto größer ist die Gefahr eines
womöglich größeren Krieges aber es ist
offenbar ein Punkt erreicht den man im
Westen sieht dass man sagt sei es nun um
Kriegsziele zu erreichen oder wie ich
finde einfach um dem Land sich die
Möglichkeit geben sich zu verteidigen
und sein Territorium zu beschützen und
seine Menschen zu beschützen dass man
doch sagt wir müssen mehr tun halte ich
aber nicht unbedingt in der Abfolge
dafür jetzt für einen Indiz das
Deutschland also auch die berühmten Leos
liefern wird auch wenn die Forderungen
die es ja das ganze Jahr schon gibt
Marie Agnes Streck Zimmermann von der
FDP Anton Hofreiter von den Grünen in
vorderster Linie das Scholz auch da sagt
klar machen wir da wird es wieder lange
Gespräche geben und da wird man vor
allem auf die Amerikaner warten also die
ausmesserin hat es ja auch wieder gesagt
man muss miteinander tun hat ja jetzt
auch nicht gesagt wenn wir liefern
Leopard
obwohl grün aber ja immer doch eine
derer war die schon auch im Sommer
Interviews gegeben hat und gesagt hat
wir müssen da vorangehen also ich denke
sie ist ja immer ein Schritt vor dem
Kanzler aber klar die Linie der
Regierung insgesamt
was für ein Unterschied macht ist oder
wie wichtig ist das dass Deutschland
jetzt gesagt hat dass die Marder
Schützenpanzer geliefert werden
ja das ist natürlich so ein großer
Schritt zuvor und ja also die Ukraine
fragte man mich ständig also was hält
die deutschen davon zu liegen und die
Deutschen haben die panzerhaube
geliefert die immer zwei Systeme diesen
mehrfach Raketenwerfer eines t-himmel
über die Ukraine sind uns sehr dankbar
dafür und auch die Panzerfaust haben wir
geliefert aber warum keine Panzer was
macht der Unterschied also die ähm
Raketenwerfer oder die Panzer also
braucht man um die Städte zu befreien
warum sie für Deutschland keine
Fahrzeuge und ich musste immer erklären
ja also man will keinen ersten Schritt
machen und so weiter und so fort das
verstehen sie nicht aber mindestens wird
die deutsche Position also
verständlicher was ich gerne betonen
wollte also diese also diese These also
Eskalation
die Russen können nicht geschlagen
werden das hören wir seit Monaten von
von allen ehemaligen Experten
die meisten Experten also generalbad
oder Professor Warwick die sagten immer
über die russische angebliche
eskalationsdominanz und gestärkt ich
wurde immer die Rede sein also die
Ukraine werden nie Kiefer und Gebiete
befreien nie Ukraine werden nie Person
betreiben Ukraine werden nie also ihre
Truppen von dornbuz raten also morgen
werden sie eingekesselt werden von der
mächtigen russischen Armee die Russen
sind unbesiegt also alles ist sorry als
ein Quatsch irgendwie also die Russen
können geschlagen werden
geschlagen ihres kämpfen seit drei
Monaten vergeblich und so wenige kleine
Schnitte im Osten also sie sagen sie
können Sie mir Unterstützung haben
geht darum vor allem dass wir den
Ukrainern in dem Kampf welchen die
Ukraine gewinnen dass wir ihnen Hilfe
leisten es geht nicht darum diesen Krieg
zu eskalieren wir es angeblich gemeint
wird sondern um diesen Krieg zu
verkürzen und diese Verkürzung wird
dadurch erreicht dass die russische
Truppen zurückgeschlagen werden und dass
die Ukraine endlich frei leben und das
ist machbar das haben über 60% des
Direktorin schon
befreiten im April erobert haben
wenn wir jetzt sagen das wenn man dem
folgen was ja so ein Lenny sagt dass das
so funktionieren kann was macht Mathe
heißt das jetzt konkret wie schnell
funktioniert das also wir haben ja lange
gebraucht mit der Bundesregierung sich
dafür zu entscheiden diese Panzer zu
liefern also wie lange dauert es bis die
wirklich einsatzfähig sind und was würde
es ausmachen wenn jetzt Leopard 2 da
noch wäre also wie bei den
vorangegangenen Lieferungen es ist immer
ein gewisser Zeit Verzug also die
Entscheid wird getroffen zu liefern dann
kommt die Ausbildung dann wird geliefert
also es war auch bei dem Panzerhaubitzen
so bei den Raketenwerfern ist ja nicht
so dass der Kanzler sagt wir liefern und
morgen rollt der Zug und dann sind die
da und es geht los also es geht das
Training los acht Wochen dürfte es
mindestens dauern
und so ähnlich ist es auch bei den
Leoparden und das ist glaube ich ein
Problem dass ich sehe bei diesen
deutschen Entscheidungen die irgendwann
gefallen sind ohne dass sie langfristig
vorbereitet waren also es war bei der
geschützten so Panzerhaubitzen es ist
jetzt bei den Mardern so die
Entscheidung fällt es wird geliefert und
alle fangen an zu überlegen meine Güte
wie kann man denn organisieren Lieferung
Ausbildung Nachschub Technik anstatt zu
sagen es könnte doch sein wir machen das
demnächst und dann bereit mir das schon
mal vor also das ist keine richtige
Strategie es gibt ganz offensichtlich
keine Energie und das gleiche befürchte
befürchte ich bei den
leopard-kampfpanzern auch ich bin
ziemlich sicher wir werden irgendwann in
den nächsten Tagen und Wochen die
Entscheidung sehen für eine Lieferung
nicht unbedingt primär aus Deutschland
sondern aus anderen Ländern mit
deutscher Unterstützung und Zusage aber
dann wird es wieder bei Null losgehen
was macht das außer zu macht das ist
keine klare Strategie gibt vielleicht
auch keine klare Strategie die eben sagt
wir wollen dann nicht so viel liefern
sondern wir wollen auf eine andere Art
versuchen in diesem Krieg eine Stimme zu
haben naja die strategielosigkeit
besteht ja auf beiden Seiten weder hat
Putin eine für ihn gesichtswaren der
Exit Strategie aus diesem Krieg es gab
die Hoffnung nach der letzten
läuferhandlungsrunde zwischen einer
ukrainischen russischen
Regierungsdelegation am 29 März Istanbul
dass das Paket was damals auf dem Tisch
lag vorgelegt von der ukrainischen
Regierung ein Paket gewesen wäre mit dem
Putin gesichtswarnt hätte sagen können
habt ja was erreicht mit meiner
sogenannten spezialoperation das beendet
das hat sich aus Gründen über die zu
reden ist zerschlagen aber der Westen
hat eben auch keinerlei exit Strategie
aus diesem Krieg und ich widerspreche
Hand zu lernen ja auch ich verstehe das
Bestreben und auch dem feindigen
Unterschied den Frau Münstermann gemacht
hat zwischen sich dem Land helfen sich
zu verteidigen oder aber Kriegsziele das
ist ja ein und dasselbe auch das Ziel
sich erfolgreich zu verteidigen in dem
Sinne wie sie es beschrieben haben halte
ich mittel und langfristig für
unrealistische solieren nicht und da
soll man sich auch nicht die Welt
schöner reden bei allen Problemen die
die Russen hatten und haben und den
erfolgreichen teilweisen Rückeroberungen
durch die ukrainischen Streitkräfte
alles konzidiert aber wenn sie sich die
größten finden sich einfach angucken wie
viele Männer Putin in diesen Krieg noch
zwingen kann das sind Potenzial von
dreieinhalb Millionen jetzt ist gerade
gestern eine neue Teil Mobilisierung
angekündigt worden von 500.000 Männern
meine Befürchtung ist eben dass wir auf
einen langen langen Weg zu steuern mit
noch viel viel mehr Todesopfern und
Zerstörung an deren Ende Kiew und
Lemberg so aussehen wie Grosny nach dem
zweiten Tschetschenienkrieg und das
Russland diesen Krieg letzten Endes
militärisch gewinnt das ist meine
Befürchtung deswegen von Lemberg dann
unter russischer Fahne wehen also dass
man sozusagen ein Überfall auf ein
souveränes Land einfach hinnimmt
überhaupt nicht wobei es Menschen in der
Ukraine gibt ich mache mir das nicht zu
eigen die allerdings zu sagen eine
Besatzung die ja auch nicht das Ende vom
Lied gewesen wäre da hätte es
dauerhaften Widerstand gegeben Russland
hätte die auch keine nie unter Kontrolle
bekommen aber eine solche Besatzung wäre
möglicherweise das vergleichsweise
geringere Übel im Vergleich zu all den
Zerstörungen und Tod ich mache mir das
nicht zu eigen aber ich höre solche
Stimmen auch aus der Ukraine aber nicht
nein
ich rotiere dafür jetzt alle
Anstrengungen zu unternehmen zumindest
eine Waffenruhe herbeizuführen und dann
dann auch politische Verhandlungen
für eine Propaganda von ihm gehalten
also da brauche ich keine Belehrung aber
es geht doch darum dass
Kiew entscheiden muss ich glaube die
Strategie zu sagen wir tragen als Westen
dann Scheidung liegt letztendlich in den
Händen des Landes überfallen wurde
die darf jetzt auch wieder sprechen ja
bitte schön danke schön danke
kommunikation ist ein bisschen
kompliziert ich glaube ich bin hier der
einzige in der Runde der
gewisse Zeit meines Lebens seine
russische Staatsbürger war und auch eine
Ausbildung bei der russischen Armee
hatte also dann würde ich gerne
widersprechen also da da da machen die
Russen viel Pia also mit mit ihrer
Stärke wir wissen dass die wenigen also
die wenigen weniger als Dutzend zuerst
jetzt so vielleicht so 20 30
Raketensysteme welche wir in die Ukraine
geliefert haben und bisher und
eine einzige Luft aber Flughafen System
haben die Russen dazu gezwungen dass die
russischen fliege nicht mehr über die
Ukraine fliegen und das die russische
jetzt Munition gehabt
also da wenig ich höre das Russland
unbesiegbar wäre also wenn sorry wenn 20
30 westlich gestellten westlich
hergestellt auf der Lese Systeme die
russische Omi dazu zum Rückzug zwingen
kann was soll geredet werden wenn wir
genug warten liefern das Nummer eins
Nummer zwei ist die Russen können egal
wie viele ankündigen machen über die
Mobilisierung wir wissen aber dass in
der Realität sie keinen Nenner
mobilisieren können über eine Millionen
von Russen und jungen Russen sind jetzt
geflohen aus dem Lande nach Kaufhaus ist
noch andere Republiken wir wissen dass
wir wissen vergeblich die Insassen aus
dem Gefängnissen vollkommen und
unfähigen Leute zum Militärdienst also
wird hier viele Jahre im Knast saßen und
kann diese Disziplin kennen natürlich
keine Kämpfe sind versuchten sie zum
Teil Zwangs zu mobilisieren und sie sind
meistens schon tot wir Russen versuchten
alle möglichen Gruppen der Bevölkerung
einschließlich die Gastarbeiter aus
Zwangs zu rekrutieren sie haben keine
Männer also wenn Sie schauen so welche
Männer sie restrikotieren also die sind
also nach Papieren 40 Jahre alt sehen
viel älter aus leiden vom Alkoholkonsum
von anderen Problemen in der Gesundheit
und sind vor allem nicht ausgebildet und
auch wenn Sie eine Millionen
unausgebildeten älteren Länder sammeln
die machen keine Armee sie haben keine
Offiziere die haben keine Ausbildung
sind keine eingebildetes Team und die
Ukraine sind höchst motiviert und sie
beweisen es uns täglich sie befreien
ihre Städte die einzige großstadtzentrum
so als eine regionhauptstadt welche die
Russen besetzt haben Anfang des Krieges
und in den ersten Wochen mit dem
Überraschungsangriff und haben die
Ukraine befreit obwohl alle sagten alle
mit denen ich diskutierte in den letzten
Monaten das ist unmöglich
zulassen das machen die Ukraine trotzdem
ist ja hier befürchten Menschen wenn wir
wenn der Westen zu stark sich einmischt
in diesen Konflikt und viele sagen mit
dem Leopard 2 ist dann eine Grenze
überschritten ist eine rote Linie
überschritten dann ist eben die Gefahr
groß zum Beispiel eines atomschlages
oder auf eine andere Art eine Eskalation
ich würde ich gerne sieht
wir schon seit Monaten haben
der greift uns an wenn er will der
braucht keine rote Linien der braucht
keine Provokation angebliche dass die
Rede von den NATO Erweiterung war für
ihn immer die Propaganda und das einzige
was ihm hält ist der militärische die
militärische Stärke und wir müssen diese
militärische Stärke zugreifen
ich sehe das ziemlich ähnlich der Punkt
ist einfach wir haben oder Deutschland
hat bei bei jedem Punkt bei dem was doch
geliefert wurde immer wieder gesagt dass
eine rote Linie das geht nicht und dann
ging es doch also zu glauben dass man
liefert man den Panzer mit der 20 mm
Kanone geht noch mit der 25 mm Kanone
ist schon die rote Linie und der
Atomkrieg und 30 mm ist der sofortige
Weltuntergang also das wäre der rote
Linie wäre natürlich schon wenn wenn
NATO
-verbotszone
aus ihrer Sicht völlig zurecht aber das
ist eine rote Linie die gehalten wird
und wurde und dazu führt dass die NATO
mit eigenen Soldaten vereinfacht gesagt
in diesen Krieg eingreift das ist die
Linie wo verständlicherweise alle sagen
das geht nicht das darf nicht sein NATO
Soldaten wenn die Ukraine ausbilden dann
ist es kein Einheiten aber die Frage ist
ja wer definiert das und wir wie das
Problem ist natürlich es gibt auf der
einen Seite die völkerrechtliche
Definition auf der anderen Seite die
Putin Definition die beiden müssen nicht
übereinstimmen nein das tun sie nicht an
dem Punkt sind wir uns offensichtlich
alle einig es gibt die völkerrechtliche
und da ist völlig klar rein
völkerrechtlich ist sowohl die Lieferung
von Waffen an anderen angegriffenes Land
in Ordnung auch die Ausbildung von
Soldaten nur wenn dann eben deutsche
oder andere Soldaten aktiv mit kämpfen
würden es selbst das würde Russland
nicht das Recht geben deswegen auf NATO
Länder zu schießen weil Russland hier
nein nach dem Frieden Völkerrecht nicht
aber der entscheidende Punkt ist und das
haben sie eben auch schon gesagt das ist
eine völlig überflüssige Diskussion denn
das wird willkürlich Putin für ihn
definieren was für ihn der Punkt ist wo
die Nato und rote Linie überschreitet
und worauf er dann möglicherweise
reagieren will deswegen halten
aber es gibt natürlich mit Blick auf
bestimmte Waffensysteme schon rote Linie
also nehmen wir die Artilleriegeschütze
und das ist eine die in der NATO
vereinbart ist das hat nichts mit
deutscher Zurückhaltung zu tun dass die
Ukraine bisher keine Artilleriegeschütze
mit mehr als 40 km keine Reichweite hat
das öffentliche erklärt hat gesagt wir
wollen nicht dass die ukrainischen
Streitkräfte in der Lage sind ihrerseits
ausgesicherte Entfernung von der
russischen Grenze bis tief in Russisch
System zu schießen das ist ein rote
Linie die bisher jedenfalls gezogen
wurde und das bedeutet auf der anderen
Seite aber eine gewisse Überlegenheit
weil die russischen Streitkräfte haben
ihrerseits antillengeschütze die bis 120
km schießen aber das wäre eine echte
Verein
der deutschen Diskussion finde ich das
haben sie vorhin gesagt es wird immer so
ungeordnet ist natürlich jetzt auch
schon also Anfang Januar entscheiden wir
uns als Land der Kanzler doch Marder zu
liefern dann ist die Frage wie viele wo
kommen die eigentlich her jetzt hören
wir die sollten die
Verteidigungsministerin Schloss noch aus
dass es aus eigenen Beständen geht jetzt
heißt es in jüngsten Berichten sie habe
mit Griechenland telefoniert und denen
ähm beigebracht dass die sozusagen das
was für Sie gedacht waren dann erstmal
zur Verfügung stellen also ich glaube
die ungeordnete deutsche Diskussion hat
immer auch ganz viel damit zu tun dass
man sich offensichtlich zwischen
Kanzleramt und Ministerium nicht so ganz
abstimmt oder das Kanzleramt das längst
übernommen hat und auf der anderen Seite
gar nicht so genau klar ist wie sind wir
selber aufgestellt was können wir
abgeben was kann man sofort einsetzen
und vielleicht wo muss man das
Auslandshilfe bitten und diese Leo Frage
ist ja auch mehr die Frage würde
Deutschland Spanien etwa erlauben
Leoparden abzugeben und die Genehmigung
zu erteilen
Deutschland da so zögerlich ist weil man
sagt weil wir stimmen alles gemeinsam ab
und das ist eben offensichtlich
abstimmen will dann könnte Deutschland
ja auch also Anton hofreitertes der
letzte Woche gesagt Deutschland könnte
ja auch mal Führung zeigen also es war
ja jetzt wieder so dass aber das ist
genau das was Scholz eben nicht als sein
politisches Ziel erkennt in dieser
Kriegs
sag mal in diesem Krieg Führung zu
zeigen Komma auch mit den Umfragen im
Hinterkopf die ja zeigen dass in der
deutschen Bevölkerung wenn auch die
Ampel viel in der Kritik steht aber sein
Kurs in dieser in dieser
Auseinandersetzung gar nicht so
laut dem geteilt ja laut dem letzten ZDF
Politbarometer sind mehr Bürger für die
Lieferung von modernen Kampfpanzern also
43% waren es Anfang November jetzt sind
es 48 Prozent also das steigert sich und
nur noch
dagegen aber die Entscheidung war dazu
liefern ist gar nicht so gut angekommen
also ich glaube da kann man jetzt auch
die Zahlen das Problem
Deutschland macht keinen Alleingang das
hat ja eine Kehrseite und die Kehrseite
ist wenn man sich mit Partnern auf etwas
verständigt dann muss man es auch tun
und komischerweise war Deutschland und
die Bundesregierung sehr schnell zu
sagen kein allein kann und jetzt wo die
Partner sagen macht doch ist Deutschland
gar nicht schnell zu sagen ach ja kein
allein die Partner sagen okay dann
machen wir mit also das finde ich
unlogisch und nicht besonders
Regierung sagt die wollen breitere
koalitions davon mehreren Ländern also
ist das nur noch eine Frage der Zeit
dass Deutschland Leopard 2 liefert wenn
das so wichtig ist für diesen
Kriegsverlauf vor diesem Hintergrund
würde ich ganz stark vermuten ja ich
würde sagen es kommt auf Joe Biden und
die Amerikaner an und dann wird
Deutschland ziehen oder nicht ziehen
dazu noch was bedeutet das ist das ein
großes eine Sekunde super und dann sehe
hier so wieder ist das ein auch vor
allen Dingen ein ganz großes Symbol
dieser Leopard 2 Panzer inzwischen oder
ist es tatsächlich so dass damit einfach
noch mal eine ganz andere Art der
Unterstützung von Deutschland gewährt
wird also es hat einmal eine Symbolkraft
weil der Leopard 2 Panzer ist derjenige
der in den Debatten der letzten 30 Jahre
wo ich auch umrüstungsexporte und Panzer
Export an andere Länder gegen immer im
Fokus wunderbar das war die Debatte an
Saudi-Arabien an an der Türkei es war
immer der es war nie der Puma oder der
Mörder von daher hat es eine gewisse
symbolische Bedeutung natürlich würde er
aufgrund der verstärkten Kampfkraft der
Wiegold hat das ja alles schon
beschrieben
zusätzliche militärische Unterstützung
bringen aber auch da bleibe ich bei dem
Punkt nicht erreichbar ist das damit
verbundene Ziel und er hat zu Lenny also
ich bin ja selber zwar kein Militär aber
das hier eine große skeptisch skepsis
herrscht dass die von Ihnen
beschriebenen Ziele erreichbar sind das
sagt ja nun unter anderem der
Generalstabschef der amerikanischen
Streitkräfte das Sagen führende aktive
aber auch deutsche und andere NATO
generelle liegen die alle völlig falsch
das ist anfangs fehlereinschätzung
gegeben hat das wissen wir beide auch
Putin ist von seinen militärführern
offensichtlich nicht richtig informiert
worden über das was die Streitkräfte
können und nicht können und das ist auch
korrigiert worden aber das all die die
jetzt sagen dass dieses militärisch
weder die Ukraine gewinnen kann
und aber Putin auch nicht das sind doch
nicht irgendwelche her gelaufenen Leute
die keine Ahnung hätten vom
militärischen Geschäft
von also am Anfang waren viele von
Skepsis überfüllt jetzt höre ich nie mit
dem so aus den seriösen der Welt also
die Bundeswehr gehört offensichtlich
nicht dazu
Ukraine ihre Gebiete zurück oder nicht
gefragt also in Deutschland gibt es okay
wir sind dafür bekannt dass unsere
generelle ziemlich oft daneben liegen
generalbad wird Ukraine in wenigen
Wochen
was wichtig ist in diesem Krieg es gab
eine einzige Einschränkung von
Amerikanern gegenüber der Ukraine was
Ukraine mit ihren Waffen machen nicht
dürfen und zwar sie dürfen nicht dazu
Siren Russlands attackieren das heißt
kein bremskurs Quelle rot oder ironisch
etc das haben die Grünen nicht gemacht
die ukrainische Artillerie welche wir in
geliefert haben nach zwei oder Heimat
wir haben Reichweite von 80 Kilometern
nicht 40 und 80 Kilometer so eine
Reichweite mit der Präzision von bis zu
fünf Meter viele höchstens hat keine
russische Artillerie deswegen haben die
Ukraine die russischen Aktie geschossen
Lage ausgeschaltet und die russische
konnte nicht mehr die Feuerwehr als
einsetzen und dann was was gerne machen
also das machte die russische Armee zum
halten also
die Ukraine haben aber nie der
Versuchung gefallen diese Reichweite
gegen das russische souveräne
Direktorium auszunutzen zum Beispiel um
die russischen Beschüsse und zivilen
Gebiete im Kaki zu stoppen der Karte
fliegt wie gesagt 50 km von der
russischen Grenze wurde vom russischen
geschossen die Ukraine konnten die
Heimat einsetzen und diese Positionen
auszuschalten das haben sie nie gemacht
sie haben aufgrund von unseren
Einschränkungen ihre Zivilisten opfern
müssen damit sie kein Krieg produzieren
zwischen Russland zu den USA Deutschland
sagen wir was also das ist schon ein
Beweis der Zurückhaltung zurückhaltens
der Ukraine Ukraine haben die Krim
attackiert ja die können sich Ukraine
ist von Russland
illegal besetzt und das dürfen sie
das wissen
wir können den Ukraine wir können den
Ukraine Waffen die dann welche die
gesagt keine sehr gezielt einsetzen
keine Kollateralschaden keine Angriffe
gegen großes Telefon wir könnten
welche sie zu Befreiung ihre Direktorin
was die Ukraine schon erfolgreich machen
weit und schneller machen und wichtig
ist dann dann mache ich Schluss wichtig
ist dass die Armeen und die Nationen
helfen die werden nicht vergessen werden
die Amerikaner
und unsere Waffen können jetzt zum
ersten Mal seit fast 100 Jahren können
Sie russischen können die die Deutschen
panzersysteme und die deutschen
Waffensysteme für was Gutes eingesetzt
werden und wir konnten ähnlich in den
gebeten wo unsere Panzer für dutzende
Jahre für Größe Taten für Grausamkeit
ist Krieges ein Inbegriff waren können
sie ähnlich Freiheit Frieden und reden
funktioniert das ist jetzt die Frage wie
das in der deutschen Politik wirklich
weiter umgesetzt wird Frau Münstermann
weil gerade auch in der Koalition wird
gerade der kann natürlich auch getrieben
von FDP von grünen also was erwarten sie
da jetzt in der weiteren Diskussion ja
das ist schon erstaunlich ich habe mir
das eben gedacht bei Frau bärburg im Zug
das also eine grüne Außenministerin
dafür wird oder werden muss dass man
Panzer liefert um Menschenleben zu
retten hat sie gesagt also
zeigt schon was dieses Jahr an
Zeitenwende auch bedeutet ich glaube
Olaf Scholz lässt sich von den Stimmen
wie die immer ganz vorne sind aus der
Koalition FDP grüne nicht drängen
interessant ist dass er von seiner SPD
die sich geradezu in der Klausurtagung
getroffen hat die Spitze möchte nicht
sagen eine Blankoscheck aber ein
bisschen was schon das also die da hat
keiner mehr gemuckt die Fraktion ist ja
eigentlich relativ Friedens bewegt
gewesen gerade am Anfang da sagt man
jetzt aber auch von Seiten der
Parteiführung in mir tragen das mit wie
der Kanzler entscheidet Komma in
Abstimmung mit unseren Partnern also das
ist so das Credo auf was man sich gerade
verständigt ich glaube das gibt ihm in
gewisse Sicherheit denn die SPD ist die
kritischste was Waffenlieferungen angeht
die kritischste Fraktion ich denke dass
wenn Annalena Werbung und Robert Habeck
der Leo Lieferung auch nicht
ausgeschlossen hat wenn die weiter Druck
machen würden das dann hätte er ein
Problem ich glaube die Stimmen die es
gerade gibt treiben Olaf Scholz nicht
wirklich nach vorne die EU-Kommission
genau
aber also ich glaube das Verhältnis ist
ohnehin nicht das beste zwischen Frau
von der Leyen und Herr Scholl Herrn
Scholz am Ende muss man sagen er war
immer skeptisch auch bei einer
EU-Mitgliedschaft der Ukraine dann stand
er in der ukrainischen Boden und hat das
verkündet zusammen mit europäischen
Partnern die Bewegung wird schon in
diese Richtung gehen aber er wird ganz
sicher nicht der Erste sein der sich
bewegt die Frage ist aber zu mach sie
sagen ja man muss schauen dass man ja
dass man letztendlich auf eine
Verhandlungssituation auch kommt wo
könnte Deutschland denn da was bewirken
wenn sie sagen Waffenlieferung wäre
nicht ihre ihre Rezepte sozusagen also
wie kann man für andere Art vielleicht
noch aktiv werden also Deutschland
könnte sich dafür einsetzen dass die
äußeren Akteure die hier Einfluss nehmen
müssen auf die beiden unmittelbaren
Kriegsparteien das auch tun das ist mit
Blick auf Putin vor allem die Regierung
aus derjenigen Länder im globalen Süden
die unter den Folgen dieses Krieges am
meisten leiden also Stichwort
verschärfte Ernährungskrise erhöhte
Energiepreise und so weiter und seien es
Indien Südafrika Brasilien und so weiter
dass die zusammen mit dem
UNO-Generalsekretär den Putin ganz klar
machen du bist verantwortlich für die
Folgen dieses Krieges sind nicht die
westlichen Sanktionen was da immer
behauptet wird und ihn zu einem
zumindest schon Erwachen Ruhe das wäre
ein erster Schritt drängen auf der
anderen Seite müssen es natürlich der
Westen sein aber hier im Klartext die
Amerikaner die dem selenski sagen auch
deine rigide Linie mit Putin rede ich
überhaupt nicht das geht nicht das hat
man nie mehr auch schon vor Weihnachten
mal vorsichtig bedeutet dass er diese
Linie aufgeht aber es muss mehr kommen
ich bin im übrigen der Überzeugung es
geht nicht darum der ukrainischen
Regierung zu sagen worüber sie zu reden
zu verhandeln hätte oder gar welche
Konzessionen sie zu machen hätte das
nicht auf der anderen Seite wissen wir
aber doch was die
Verhandlungsgegenstände im Wesen hier
sind ich wiederhole sie lagen am 29
Platz vorgelegt von der ukrainischen
Regierungsdelegation auf dem Tisch auf
dem Verhandlungstisch und das sind doch
die Kernfragen es ist die Frage der
NATO-Mitgliedschaft ist die Frage des
künftigen Status des Donbass über der
verhandelt werden sollte Krim es ist die
Frage von verlässlichen jetzt lassen Sie
mich bitte auch mal ausreden also
entschuldigung aber der hat eben sehr
lange geredet es sind die verlässlichen
Sicherheitsgarantien die die Ukraine
natürlich braucht von einer ganzen Reihe
von Ländern die auch benannt sind das
sind die Fragen aber ich denke bevor das
passiert muss es bestimmte Signale von
Washington an Putin geben bestimmte
Dinge muss Putin aus Washington hören da
reicht es nicht aus zum Beispiel die
Frage der NATO-Mitgliedschaft wo er in
dem Vorschlag gesagt wird der
rheinischen Regierung wir wollen das gar
nicht mehr aber verlässlich ja
schon nicht von mir ausgedacht sondern
hat die silence-regierung vorgelegt
keine NATO-Mitgliedschaft Neutralität
ist das muss Putin glaube ich aus
Washington hören damit es ein Einfluss
hat das reicht nicht wenn das jetzt
inzwischen im Moment zurückgezogen aus
Kiew kommt das wäre so ein Signal und
dann direkt die Verhandlung irgendwann
zu ermöglichen sehen sie eine Chance auf
Verhandlung im Moment sehe ich keine
weil die russischen in Anführungszeichen
Verhandlungsangebote
kapitulationsforderungen sind
im Moment so sind wir uns eigentlich
eindeutig dass diese Moskau kommt ist
ihr kapituliert und darüber können wir
reden und sonst können wir über nichts
reden das aber nicht das Ende vom Leben
und dann das ist muss nicht das Ende vom
Lied sein so lange aber diese
Maximalforderung da ist sie sich
eigentlich überhaupt keinen Spielraum
und auch die ich möchte mal kurz
eingehen auf die Angebote der Ukraine
vor schon fast einem Jahr der Krieg hat
sich seitdem weiterentwickelt
es sind natürlich gewisse Dinge das zum
Beispiel Sicherheitsgarantien für die
Ukraine angeht daher hat man heute
glaube ich ein ganz anderen Blick drauf
als für den vor 10 11 12 Monaten hatten
wer soll die denn geben wie soll er die
geben es gab mal sowas ähnliches nämlich
das Budapester Memorandum nachdem die
Ukraine der Atomwaffen abgegeben hat das
hat alles nicht funktioniert wird man
neu sehen müssen ich möchte und das ist
eigentlich der Punkt das schließt sich
aber nicht aus oder schließt nicht aus
dass man der Ukraine in ihrem
Verteidigungskampf trotzdem hilft ich
sehe das als zwei nötige Schritte oder
wäre das vielleicht sogar noch eine
Stärkung für die Verhandlungsposition
das sozusagen Putin die die Sprache der
Stärke der eher versteht also es wird ja
immer behauptet Putin verstünden nur die
Sprache der Stärke ob das an der Stelle
funktioniert vermag ich nicht
einzuschätzen ich denke wenn man der
Ukraine auch eine bessere verteidigungs-
und auch sagen wir es ganz klar
rückerobungsmöglichkeit besetzte Gebiete
gibt schwächt man nicht ihre
Verhandlungsposition
also Lenny denken Sie haben Sie
irgendeine Hoffnung auf Verhandlungen
dass das eine mögliche Art gibt hat ist
diesen Krieg zu beenden und was erwarten
Sie davon Deutschland mit der Bitte um
etwas kürzere Antworten
ja gerne danke also zuerst wir wissen
aus unserer Erfahrung das war der Putin
die Behandlungen nur dafür ausnutzt
immer damit er sich neu formiert die
Kräfte sammelt und erneut angreift weil
er irgendwelchen Anlass findet um zu
erklären warum diese Angriff
gerechtfertigt wird also das wissen also
kurze Sprache wenn du keine donaust wird
die ukrainische Seite hat schon
signalisiert die seinen Bereich für die
Gespräche das hat außen ist der Kollege
gesagt für eine Woche bei einem
Interview und da sind die Bedingungen
ganz klar und ich glaube wir sind die
einzige realistischen Bedingungen das
heißt Bedingungen welche den stabilen
Frieden garantieren können das heißt
der russischen Grenze entlang der
Ukraine der komplette Abzug wäre aus dem
besetzten Gebieten in der Ukraine und
die Auslieferung der russischen
Kriegsverbrecher an den Haaren in
Russland das macht dann ist es die
richtige Gäste des guten Willens und das
zeigt dass Russland wirklich den Frieden
will und nicht eine Feuerpause damit
Russland wie Herr Kollege von Details
und gesagt hat die neuen Männer
mobilisiert und dann erneut ein Angriff
mit einem Angriff beginnt und dann
diskutieren wir erneut ob wir der
Ukraine helfen müssen oder nicht die
Verhandlungen müssen geführt werden mit
den Leuten welche bewiesen haben dass
sie an Behandlung glauben und dass sie
an den kompromistern erreichen
Kompromissen festhalten werden Russen
hat bisher eine sehr schlechte
Geschichte also und kann das nicht
beweisen das Beweis dass die dann
Kompromissen hält dann können wir keine
aussprechen da die Ukraine sind die
letzten Nationen welche den Vorsätze und
die Fortsetzung dieses kriegt dieses
Kriege sich wünscht da es sind die
Ukraine welche leiden welche sterben du
kriegstädte weg zerstört werden und ich
glaube nicht dass die Ukraine ist aus
Spaß machen und die Frage ist ja auch
wie lange das überhaupt alles noch
dauert und es in der Diskussion ist ja
auch dass es möglicherweise noch eine
weitere große russische Offensive gibt
wann kann das noch sein dass der Krieg
sich so dramat noch weiterentwickelt das
sozusagen ja dann doch noch der Druck
noch weiter erhöht wird und dass man
dass man vielleicht noch über ganz
andere
eingriffsmittel da sprechen muss ich
glaube das Jahr hat gezeigt dass wir mit
allem rechnen müssen hätten wir auch
nicht vorstellen können dass es die
ukrainische
Infrastruktur mal Kriegsziel wird also
die Idee schnell raus schnell rein oder
irgendwelche Gebiete zu annektieren ist
ja jetzt in so ein
ein Kampf wo der eine mal da Gewinne
macht mal dort aber trotzdem gibt es
jeden Abend Luftalarm in vielen Teilen
der Ukraine klar kann es immer schlimmer
werden ich glaube was für Deutschland
interessant ist und auch für die Ukraine
wichtig also wir haben irgendwie das
klingt ziemlich aber wir haben ja so
gelernt mit dem Krieg zu leben also bei
uns spielte ganz viel die Frage nach
Energie Knappheit Preisen und so weiter
eine Rolle diese Diskussion hat sich
beruhigt jetzt schauen wir wieder
verstärkt
in die Ukraine dass es glaube ich für
das Land gut aber die Frage ist immer
wie weit kriegt auch die Politik ihre
Leute mitgenommen und glaube jeder je
länger der Krieg dauert schon auch das
Problem der der Abnutzung sozusagen in
denen Gesellschaften die ja zurzeit auch
noch ganz viel leisten also wir haben
über die Flüchtlinge und so weiter noch
gar nicht gesprochen die ja alle
westlichen Länder auch aufnehmen und da
bin ich sehr gespannt wie also die Zeit
spielt wahrscheinlich für Putin und
deswegen sollte es Lösungen geben
Verhandlungen aufzunehmen ich glaube es
gäbe keinen Politiker der das nicht
unterstützen würde die Frage ist nur von
welchem Standpunkt aus sie haben was
erklärt also mit
kapitulationsforderungen wird nicht
weitergehen jetzt mal was denken Sie wie
lange dieser Krieg noch dauern wird also
wenn das so weitergeht in der
Entwicklung der Politik dann wird es
noch sehr sehr lange dauern ich will
nicht alles wiederholen was gesagt hat
mit sehr viel mehr Opfern und es wird
nicht auf das hinauslaufen was heißt
sondern die sich als Ziel vorstellt was
man weint wegen auch euch wünschen kann
aber ich halte es bleibe dabei für für
unrealistisch und deswegen werden vor
allem die Amerikaner entscheiden müssen
wann endlich der Zeitpunkt kommt hier
ernsthaft diplomatische versuche zu
machen dass es wahrscheinlich weder eine
nicht so sehr eine Frage der deutschen
Regierung ist die Frage ja wie lange es
dauert und werden die die Amerikaner
würden Sie dem zustimmen dann
letztendlich dass die entscheidende
Stimme da sein viel stärker als Europa
also ich weiß nicht ob die Amerikaner ob
die USA an dieser Stelle den nötigen
Einfluss auf Putin haben und ob das auch
so gesehen etwas ist was Aufgabe der USA
ist wir reden jetzt wenn es darum geht
zu verhindern zu verhindern dass
nukleare Eskalation kommt ja aber auf
diesem Level haben die USA da Einfluss
da habe ich erhebliche Zweifel auch
immer dass die irgendwie mit schuld sein
also das finde ich eine komische ähm
überhaupt nicht überhaupt nicht versteht
geworden wir sind leider am Ende dieser
Diskussion und leider muss man ja auch
sagen wird es nicht die letzte Phoenix
Runde sein zu diesem Thema ganz
herzlichen Dank erst um Lenny nach Liv
passen Sie auf sich auf Herr Wiegold
Frau Münstermann und Herr zu macht
vielen dank ihnen fürs zuschauen und
hier geht's weiter mit Phoenix der Tag
bis dahin tschüss
[Musik]
böse Unterstellung von Münstermann da
würde ich mich ganz entschieden geht
aber ich meine ist ja nicht mal was
passieren wird und dann werden sie alle
sagen
vielen Dank
gefunden wird bleibt das